boy joining us only on cbs this morning
is minneapolis city council member
jeremiah ellison his father
by the way is minnesota attorney general
keith ellison who is leading the
prosecution's case
against derrick chauvin we welcome you
councilman
ellison to to the table virtually
you know it is hard to watch this trial
i can't imagine what it's like for
minneapolis residents
how painful this must be but i think
many people are feeling this
you know we hear excruciating it's
dramatic it's traumatic it's very hard
to watch so
how are you processing it along with
your residents and what stood out to you
this week
you know uh thank you for having me on
the show i really appreciate it
and i appreciate the the attention that
minneapolis
is getting for you know what we're going
through it is traumatic
i think that i'm trying to keep my ear
to the ground talk to my constituents
and talk to my neighbors about what
they're feeling
um and be responsive in this moment i
think um
you know people are looking for a little
bit of leadership on the outside of the
trial of course
the people who are in it uh need to be
focused on the trial
um uh but that doesn't mean that it's
not having ramifications out in the
community and that people aren't
really feeling the weight of it yeah did
anything in particular stand out to you
this week as you were watching
you know i think that there's been some
really riveting testimony
um obviously you know watching uh
somebody like donald williams who's my
age
uh uh you know who um who we we've
actually crossed paths growing up here
in the city um and you know playing
sports against each other and that kind
of thing and so
um you know watching that and seeing
just how close and how
this thing is it really is uh it really
does feel
very close it's not some distant thing
that we're watching on tv we're seeing
our neighbors
up there you know councilman people
always say that
people who've looked at it so far say oh
man this is a slam dunk you look at that
video
you hear the testimony but as you know
you've got 12 jurors with different life
experiences
there's no such thing as a slam dunk
even if what you're seeing
seems very obvious do you think about
the outcome
of this jury of this verdict and what
that could mean to your city because the
world really
is watching this you concerned
you know i think it's not my place to be
concerned you know the folks who are
the you know the prosecution and the
folks in that room are are
are going to make the best decisions
that they can i think that no matter
what
you know here in minneapolis and i think
across the country
we can't look at what happens with this
criminal trial or what happens on the
civil side
as the totality of justice right we've
got to be focused
beyond that because no matter what the
outcome is you know we still have issues
here in our city
and we've got to be working really hard
to make sure that this doesn't happen
again
i think that justice is going to come in
the form of some really
needed change and that no matter what
the outcome is
we've got to be ready to fight for that
councilman after george floyd's death
the city council voted to reform the
police department especially
in terms of funding where does that
stand now and how do you think this
trial might impact that effort
yeah well you know the minneapolis city
council we we we took eight million
dollars from
uh the police department and really in
an effort to expand
uh how it is that we keep our neighbors
safe i think for so long
the police have been synonymous with
safety and we're finding
not only in this case but but also in
other instances around the city that
they're not the
most appropriate response to every
emergency we do have emergencies here in
our city and
folks don't want us spending less money
on their safety
people want us making those in those
investments uh but they i think that
folks are recognizing that the police
can't handle every single
every single crisis and so uh that's
kind of where things stand
you know we've got those budget
allocations were expanding the office of
violence prevention
which is a program that we just started
in 2018
and that work has gone from roughly half
a million dollars to 2.5 million dollars
it's a lot of expansion but it's not
enough that we'll we're going to need to
continue those programs
and we're investing in a in mental
health response um and uh and also
looking to take away some of those
non-emergency calls
uh from mpd uh you know things like
fender benders that that that often cops
will respond to
we just have more appropriate you know
uses of of uh
we have more appropriate responses to
those things what kind of impact do you
think councilman that
do you think that this case will have on
your city going forward you know we we
keep hearing that feelings sometimes
matter as much as facts
in a situation like this what are your
thoughts on that
you know the people of minneapolis don't
feel any different um
right now than the people of new york
when witnessing um
you know eric gardner's uh kill or not
not not
face charges and i i think folks don't
feel any different than
it than folks in chicago felt watching
jason van dyke's trial i think that what
we're experiencing here in minneapolis
is not unique to minneapolis
uh i think unfortunately every single
city
uh uh you know some some big cities
some some small cities like ferguson uh
have experienced
what we're experiencing emotionally here
in minneapolis
i think that we're going to need to
you know learn from the past to learn
from that history
and also continue to learn in real time
you know how to be in solidarity with
those cities who who have experienced
what we're experiencing here
uh but i don't think that we can really
just take this as a local issue
um uh what we're experiencing here
goes far beyond uh minneapolis and and i
think that the questions that we're
asking ourselves here about how we keep
our neighbors safe
moving into the future are the same
questions that folks are asking
themselves
all over the city and you know you've
got examples of uh you know the mayor up
in ithaca is doing some great work
uh up there and and uh and i could sort
of name folks around the country who are
sort of asking this question
how can we better keep our neighbors
safe how can we better keep each other
safe
uh you know law enforcement's probably
gonna be a part of that uh
but it doesn't need to be the only way
jeremiah ellison you make a very good
point
unfortunately you are your city is not
alone in this we thank you for your time
this morning